الان الى ايران وجهها الحرس الثوري ضربات
بالصواريخ والطائرات المسيره ضد مقر تابعه
لاحزاب ايرانيه معارضه داخل اقليم كردستان
العراق وقال بيان باسم الحرس الثوريين
ضرباته الحقت اضرار كبيره بمن سماهم
الارهابيين في كردستان العراق ومن جهه
ذكرت وسائل اعلام ايرانيه ان اربعه صواريخ
سقطت فجر اليوم على مقر الحزب الديمقراطي
لكردستانيه الايراني في قسم جاق في محافظه
في اربيل في كردستان العراق بالتزامنه مع
تعرضي مقر حزبلاء قرب السليمانيه بشمال
العراق لهجمات بمسيرات مفخخه وافادت
مراسله الجزيره في كردستان العراق انا
سفارات الانذار دوت في القنصليه الامريكيه
في اربيل تزامنا مع القصف الايراني على
المواقع الكرديه المعرضه
ودنت القياده الوسطى الامريكيه ما وصفتها
بالضربات الصاروخيه الايرانيه عبر الحدود
والهجوم بالمسيرات على مناطق في اقليم
كردستان العراق وقال قائد القياده الوسطى
الجنرال مايكل كورولا ان الهجمات
الايرانيه التي وصفها بالعشوائيه وغير
القانونيه تعرض المدنيين للخطر وتنتهك
السياده العراقيه واضاف ان الهجمات
الايرانيه العشوائيه تعرض كذلك امنا
واستقرار العراق والشرق الاوسط للخطر على
حد تعبيره
معنى الان من طهران مراسل الجزيره عمر
هواش ومن اربيل مراسلتنا السر حكيم اهلا
بكما عمر واستير وابدا معك عمر اذا حدثنا
عن اخر ما تقوله ايران عن هذا القصر
[موسيقى]
اشتدت الاحتجاجات او ما تسميها وسائل
الاعلام الايرانيه اعمال الشغب في بعض
المدن الكرديه غرب وشمال غرب ايران تويوتا
الايراني بعد الهجمات داخل اقليم كردستان
العراق هذا الامر شاهدناه خلال الشهرين
الماضيين على وجه التحديد خلال اليوم
الماضيه شهدت بعد تلك المدن الكرديه مثل
مهابات
النشطون المحتجون بانه احتجاجات واا
مواجهات مع قوات الامن وقوات الشرطه
والحارس الثوري الايراني
او بعد وسائل الاعلام الايراني
امنيه او مؤسسات امنيه وعسكريه ومؤسسات
سياسيه ايرانيه بانها اعمال شغب وحجمات من
قبل مسلحين اكراد تقول وسائل الاميراعيه
انه تسلل من داخل كردستان العراق وانهم
يتبعون جماعات انفصاليه كرديه تتخذ من
داخل مقر كردستان العراق مقرا لها ردا على
هذه هذه الاعمال التي تصفها وسائل لا
نورانيه بعمال الشغب اضطرابات في تلك
المدن نفذ الحارس الثوري الايراني اليوم
هجمات بالصواريخ بالطائرات المسيره
المفخخه ضدها مقار في عمق اقليم كردستان
تابعه للحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني
الايراني الذي يصف هنا بانه ارهابي انفصال
كذلك اضافه الى حزب كوم الى الكردي
الايراني كذلك الذي يوصف بانه انفصالي
ويصنف على انه جماعه همم ارهابيه هذه
الهجمات مستمره منذ نحو شهرين يطالب
الحارس الثاني الايراني الحكومه العراقيه
في بغداد حكومه اربيل بنزع سلاح هذه
الاحزاب تتحول من احزاب مسلحه الى احزاب
منزوع السياحه احزاب سياسيه او من داخل
اراضي اقليم كردستان العراق السفير
الايراني في العراق يوم امس فقط قال انه
اجرم مباحثات مع الحكومه العراقيه في
بغداد تحديدا لاجل ابعاد هذه المقرات عن
الحدود الايرانيه او نزع سلاحها او حتى
انه طالب بنشر قوات تابعه لها الحكومه
المركزيه العراقيه في بغداد قرب الحدود
الايرانيه هي الحدود الايرانيه المحاضيه
لاقليم كردستان العراق بالتحديد لاجل
الحفاظ على الامن والاستقرار في تلك
المناطق ومنع تهريب السلاح الى الداخل
وهجمات
ضد القوات الايرانيه على الحدود
نعم بدايه داعيه نبدا من المواقع التي
تعرضت للقصف الشجره اليوم في اربيل وايضا
في محافظه السليمانيه في اربيل بدايه تم
قصف قضاء كوين سنجق الذي يضم مخيما
للاجئين الايرانيين المعارضين للحكومه
الايرانيه وهذا القصف على متكرر بحسب
مصادر من الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني
واصابه شخصين في هذه المنطقه اضافه الى
ذلك كان هناك قصف على مخيم ايضا بالقرب من
اربيل مخيم جيجناكان وهذا المخيم ايضا يضم
عوائل هذه الاحزاب المعارضه لايران
بالتزامن مع ذلك ايضا كان هناك قصف على
منطقه همم كويجه في محافظه السليمانيه
وهناك لم تسجل اي اصابات بحسب مصادر
المعارضه المعارضه هذه الاحزاب المعارضه
لايران تقول بان هي فارغه هذه المواقع
التي تقول الاحزاب انها فرغت هذه المواقع
همم في الايام الماضيه بعد تجدد القصف
الايراني على هذه المواقع حكومه اقليم
كردستان يوم امس كان لديها بيان اا اكدت
او نفذ في ما يتم تداوله في وسائل اعلام
ايرانيه حول استخدام همم حدود اقليم
كردستان لتهريب السلاح من داخل اقليم
كردستان الى ايران الى داخل ايران وقالت
بان اقليم كردستان لا يسمح بان يكون جانبا
او همم طرفا في عدم استقرار دول ورفض ونثم
ايتهم تداوله حول هذا الموضوع ايضا كانت
هناك صفارات الانذار دوت في القنصليه
الامريكيه داخل اربيل بالتزامن مع هذه
الضربات التي وقعت في محافظه اربيل وايضا
في السليمانيه حكومه اقليم كردستان على ما
يبدو هي اا ليس لديها حل لاخراج هذه
الاستاذ فهذه الاحزاب سوا بقى الديموقراطي
الكردستاني او اا حزب كاديحي كردستان او
كومالا هي احزاب باقيه هنا مع عوائلها
وهناك عده مخيمات في حدود اقليم كردستان
لهذه الاعوائل العائده الاحزاب المعارضه
لايران اشكرك استر حكيم من اربيل واشكر
طبعا عمر هواش من طهران